let me let me pull this story from cnn
business so we can have the last segment
just be fun
from cnn walmart apologizes for selling
juneteenth ice cream
so they tried to make a woke ice cream
and the woke attacked them for it why
are we worried about these people
what does it taste like yeah uh what are
they what do they say they say um
great value
my favorite that's why they got see see
this is why they got mad oh the branding
no no it's because everyone knows great
value is like the bargain bin
so
that's certainly why they're like hey
whoa we're not bargain bin we want ben
and jerry's that's right when they do it
it's cool yeah no juneteenth at arowan
market so what did they say they said it
was a red velvet flavored ice cream okay
what is red velvet isn't that just like
red vanilla basically right chocolate
it's just like a lot of red dying of a
little cake or something yeah cream
cheese on it wait but shouldn't it be
like chocolate ice cream i thought oh is
it chocolate juice yes right chocolate
is that right velvet i don't know i
don't know there's melon one critic
there's melanin in this cake one critic
on twitter that highlighted why it's
important to have diverse voices at the
table when making strategic business
decisions when you don't you end up
making costly foolish mistakes dude
this is the most tepid
and like
normal thing you can do to celebrate
juneteenth a holiday any holiday right
they made a holiday themed ice cream
they do it all the time we have a
maracone dream with stephen colbert and
it's you know it's great yeah
yeah
and so
i think what we actually see here is
that no matter what you do when you try
to pander to these people you'll never
win
yeah you're just you're just wasting
your time it's kind of like when your
enemies make a mistake don't stop them
but at the same time if your enemy's
making a mistake and the mistake is
destroying your environment then maybe
you need to stop them we got it we got a
fact check adrian curry said red velvet
is chocolate
really yeah okay so then it is works for
june teen yeah but it's red
and levels definitely dudes maybe that's
why they got mad i guess yeah
i don't know
buttermilk eggs hey who had an issue
with this oh this is vanilla and cocoa
so i guess we're all right
well they shouldn't have put vanilla in
it oh yeah buttery
the gall they canceled it that's crazy
they apologize they apolo walmart and
wait so they're not yelling we gotta
rush out and buy something yeah if
anyone has some send it to the show i
mean i i would love to try some
juneteenth yeah i still have the old
aunt jemima
with the old ben or the ben uh gold
uncle ben's rice i have that from we did
a cancel culture on my show i think you
had a i think it's funny how the woke
people are only getting mad about the
black people on on branding mm-hmm it's
like mr clean's fine this is butterworth
it's not even black and they got rid of
that did you guys ever read bomb pops
it's red white bomb pops it's red white
and blue that sounds racist no it's a
red white and blue uh uh what do you
call it like
that sounds very american though it's
not crazy
yeah they call it sponsored by the obama
bomb pops dude i used to eat this when i
was little it's red white and blue and
they called it it's like a bomb like how
militaristic is our society
we used
like they were teaching me as a kid drop
bombs yeah it's american of you yeah you
the ice cream the ice cream truck would
pull up and you know you'd get a bomb
pop and it was like explosively awesome
what was it even made of
cherry lime and blue raspberry no it's
water water and sugar coal tar water and
sugar the ingredients are water sugar
corn syrup and high fructose corn syrup
i just i just love that it's red white
and blue and it's a bomb
great gaddafi approved isn't it right
right now is it a dutch flag like a
dutch flag
it's not american it's right now it's
russia there you go okay
yeah yeah french i think actually oh
okay well we can we can fight over it
dutch
i just think like
you have this red white and blue for
americans it's obviously america right
it's a bomb
that should be offensive to americans
because it's like how dare you put bomb
in america together as if to imply we
think it's hilarious i think it's
awesome i think it's funny and it's like
yeah america does bomb a lot of kids
yeah so selling it but like then the
juneteenth things happen is people get
mad about everything like if somebody if
somebody you know
you see it with bench appear all the
time they'll make fun of him and he
laughs and he rolls with it he's like i
don't care dude it's funny you know i
see people post memes about me and i
think it's funny these people just want
to be angry all the time because their
life meaning if you have no meaning in
your life then of course you want to be
angry i tried to listen to angry people
i was like you know what i feel like
communication can overcome whatever we
need to so i'm like i'll give it a
chance and you listen to them and like
okay they're feeling better and then
they start then i get insulted by them
and i'm like i can only handle so much i
don't have so much time in the day i
don't want to waste 12 of my next like
at some point receiving the abuse is no
longer
tolerable
yeah we had to build a rage room in the
house it's this uh it's this small
padded room yeah because what ian will
get on twitter and they start shaking
and we're like quick get him to the room
and then we put him in he's like
ava's going to need one of those after
living with me for a little bit there is
no
twitter needed
no i mean i deal with these angry people
i mean i've i've done plenty of events
speaking events where i'll have people i
did one at university of northern
colorado and they told me i had to wear
a mask while i spoke and i said you know
no not wearing a mask while i speak and
i take the mask off as soon as i get up
on stage and these about 50 black lives
matter thugs come they're flipping the
tables they're giving death threats to
the people who are there they're taking
their mask off telling me to put my mask
on i and they're just threatening
children i mean it's really terrible
it's angry angry people i am curious
what their main complaint was with this
juneteenth thing because i would think
that this would be great but they're all
like oh you didn't have enough diversity
yeah no they're like oh no we're winning
the culture war and walmart's supporting
our ideology quick we can't claim
victimhood
get rid of it really basically oh the
revolution eats its own it does it
absolutely i just looked at the
netherlands flag is it really that
trippy is it the one where it looks like
you're looking into like a burst of
color like red white and blue all flying
past you that's it's just red white blue
oh stripes stripes i got that one but
then i got this
what are you getting
so there's the amsterdam flag which is
different than the dutch floor there we
go okay yeah that's that's the punch
flag see so your people were there were
they bomb pops yeah yeah
oh you're right the color scheme is yeah
it's just
it's dutch are you gonna bomb us
we
because the french is red white then
blue so if the bomb hop was sideways it
would be france okay so if it's flying
this way it's it's if it's sitting right
it's dutch it's not the russian flag
because the russian flag is white blue
red that's right
so it's funny i've
since ava moved into my place i put a
big dutch flag up in my place but i was
talking to her like people don't know
flags very well and i have a person who
comes and watches my dog when i go out
of town and i'm worried that he's going
to think i have this huge russian flag
in my place talking about ukraine and
everything you know i went and got
yogurt we were out on a weekend and we
all went to like a game store and got
yogurt and there's like a chalkboard
there and it was just like chalk for
anyone to draw and people drew ukrainian
flags
and it was like right around the start
of all this stuff and i was just like
this is the stupidest thing ever you
have no idea what you're supporting no
none no
it's on the trans flag now right or the
i think people were making that up
probably it could definitely be real so
i wouldn't put it past them the pride
flag has the trans triangle with the
black and brown in it and then the
rainbow to represent
folks i think they call it and now
there's one going around with yellow and
blue for ukraine but i've not seen any
official leftists like account or
organization use that yeah okay i'm
looking forward to getting away from
rectangular flags and starting new new
shapes three-dimensional flags yeah
stuff like that it's like wait is it a
square or rectangle it's a square run
attack
it's a cube attack yeah you're right
it's a cube
is it a rhombus
that means you attack they probably just
have rectangular flags because they flow
better in the wind maybe they're easier
to mass produce
yeah i'm getting kind of tired of it
it's kind of boring to look at the next
revolution that's the liberal the left
we're gonna do big tv screens instead of
flags in the future yeah it's like why
use a flag you just put up a big deal
they have plans
i mean i guess it's an elon musk
announcement flags it's obvious so you
knew if you were safe yeah but then like
you're off in the middle of nowhere and
you see a flag of your country you know
you can go there and you're saying the
enemy could fly or flag well that's what
they call fault they wouldn't because
then right but if they did they would
get attacked by their people mm-hmm
so you had to be careful about it plus
it's really you know what's always weird
to me as like rules of war where it's
like if i have a white flag i'm going to
respect that i'm like why why would
anyone do that
you know but back in the day he's like
you flew a white flag all right come on
in let's talk yeah i guess because you
want war to end so you need to have some
understanding but that was still a lot
of foul play in wars back then oh yeah
for sure no yeah
back then back then yeah now i mean this
war in ukraine is just totally honorable
and great you know no problems
whatsoever accurate media coverage
vietnam had some accurate media coverage
that was the last time they realized
we're not going to put
reporters in the war anymore we're going
to give you a cookie-cutter look at
what's happening like the first iraq war
apparently had a friend in the war
they're like yo we would laugh at the
media coverage of the tanks rolling down
the desert but like we were kicking in
doors and mowing down families it was
just horrific
the war propaganda for ukraine is just
it's it's it to me it's laughable you go
on reddit
and it's just like here's a ukrainian
soldier giving a warning to russians and
it's like some the camera's at a low
angle pointed up in a guy and he got a
cigar he's like listen you russia
everybody's hanging like ukrainian and
he's like and he flicks the cigar and
he's like we're coming for you and then
all the comments are like yes love
ukrainian and i'm like come on dude
it's just all propaganda and they're
like i loved when they reported about
mario paul getting conquered by russia
and they're like cessation of
hostilities it's like what does that
mean the fighting stopped and why
because russia won it's like okay that's
what we're trying to get to right yeah
how do you guys think of yourself like
on the balance of white pill and black
pill if you do a percentage scale
[Music]
maybe a little bit so again as a
christian myself baptized christian
about a year and a half ago i mean i'm
definitely in
i understand that all the things that
are happening now are indicative of what
human nature is i mean when you read
scripture and understand i mean these
things are kind of called out in a lot
of ways of how people are going to act
within the world it's it's basically
foretold so many of the things i'm i'm
not one to say revelations or anything
right now that's not what i'm saying but
many of the ways that humans are acting
right now is basically how humans are
going to act you will you will sin you
will go against your creator all these
kind of things and so i see that as very
natural
and so it's kind of white pilling to
know that if you have the truth on your
side then even if 99 of the culture is
against you you know what is true and
that's white pilling to me but then it's
also black pilling in the sense like
culture really sucks and there's a lot
of things that are going really terribly
right now no i've gone down the rabbit
hole a fair amount especially during the
covet days you know the vaccine mandates
and everything it came real close in
europe mandatory vaccinations in austria
it was really like it was a matter of a
month or so and then suddenly they
dropped it and for me now to get to be
here in the u.s the only reason i'm here
right now is because i was able to
travel on an exemption ground
otherwise it wouldn't have been it you
can't you can't enter the u.s unless
you're vaccinated yes that's exactly it
wow yeah the other way around same thing
so unvaccinated citizens
u.s citizens can go to europe and
unvaccinated european citizens can go to
the u.s so i was only right now right
now and nobody talks about it people
don't know this how do you get it how do
you get an exemption well i got a a
government letter because i'm gonna i'm
gonna do some humanitarian work so the
humanitarian exemption is one of them
but they're very few so and i'm a lawyer
so i got this opportunity because i have
the knowledge to do so but other people
you know i get messages from people
every day
who haven't seen their their family and
their friends in years because of these
regulations because of these
restrictions so and those are you know
those are evil
what about medical exemptions
the medical exemptions are very very
rare very rare wow yeah yeah they won't
give them out to you yeah a lot of
doctors did all this stuff no well not
for the travel for between i thought the
travel stuff ended no yeah no one knows
this no one i mean for me to come to
amsterdam all to see her i mean the the
regulations in place the things that we
had to go through was just insane now
between america and europe it's it
definitely didn't end and in europe
within europe a lot of it ended but
they're gonna
they're on you know they're still
working on the european digital identity
i don't know if you guys ever talk about
any of that not enough well you've not i
wouldn't i would love to talk to you
about it
yeah yeah so go deeper on the after show
into that if we don't what in a nutshell
what is it oh yeah well the european
digital identity project is a project by
the european commission which is
basically to make a basically a passport
a digital passport for every single
person in europe so every single
european citizen will have a digital app
that well basically the the digital
covet pass was the first stage of so
everyone in europe had a digital vax
pass i feel like a lot of americans
don't know that that was used to give
you access to like everyday things so to
go to restaurants for example you would
need to get your app scanned
to get into the restaurant so you know
vax pass is the ones that you have the
paper ones that you can you know
you couldn't in europe so you were just
excluded from society if you didn't have
this pass
there are many countries in europe that
have lifted entry requirements for
vaccination yes so
the question is once you get into the
schengen zone are you then able to go to
yeah
yeah okay so you can't fly into the
netherlands no but you can fly into
poland and then travel from there to the
netherlands no because poland is also in
the shang zone so so no you won't be
able to says poland uh well i just
pulled up schengen visa info says poland
has dropped entry requirements for
travelers for americans
it says uh
well i it just says that it also depends
on the risk of the country
restriction free entry to all travelers
well maybe they've done that now for a
couple of countries then that's good you
can see austria hasn't the netherlands
is not in there so belgium has it that's
not yeah so then with it if you are in
europe then you could go but for at
least for my country for example because
this is this is what i heard someone was
telling me that they had to fly to like
poland and then take a train okay
because they wouldn't allow you to come
in via plane well that's that's
relatively new then
because there was an eu travel ban in
force for basically the entire continent
i think this is probably the result of
the fact that they've dropped a lot of
restrictions also for europeans yeah
look at this look at this sorry to
interrupt you in the netherlands it says
travelers from third countries are still
subject to the entry rules
right makes no sense yeah but so i had
to yeah well but i mean you still would
have to get for example now vaccinated
travelers who go from europe to america
also still need to get tested
so well well hold on there we all know
the southern border has no uh security
so honestly i think it would have been
easier for me to go from this from
mexico into the u.s than to get this
exemption ground that i now have to go
in a legal way but i'm a lawyer i need
to go in a legal way you know and this
is all i can do all these things so
that's great but for other people who
don't have
the option
you know that's just it's heartbreaking
and it's it's all arbitrary it's evil
but yeah the digital the digital
identity thing that is really something
you guys should look into because it's
really really scary and that's all
that's a much bigger thing that's not
just going to include your vac status
but it's going to include biometrical
data it's going to include your taxes
it's going to include potentially even
you know central bank digital currencies
if it comes to that so the european
union is
incredibly focused on the digitalization
of your everyday life so basically your
entire life will become an airport
experience where you have to check in
and check out if it's up to these people
i was very shocked when i came to europe
and experienced that for the first time
it's so scary it's really scary i feel
like you guys should be really thankful
that it's not as far yet here yeah well
let's get in there you know we have guns
yeah right but this is this is i think
we've talked about this a lot during the
cove times you know when we had the
lockdowns and and in europe
in the netherlands it was crazy we had
curves we had the lockdowns obviously we
had the vax passes which basically track
you everywhere you go so the government
knows everything about you
whether you can go to restaurants or not
all these things were all dependent on
whether you had this digital pass and
obviously they put they are digital
they're qr codes so they're protected
against fraud so you you know you're
really screwed if you don't have them
was there a corporation that built those
or was it the government that built them
are you familiar it was a government
that built them and there was a european
system as well so they had the european
uh digital covet pass which was exactly
what it what they mentioned in the in
the reports was sort of the beginning
phase of this digital wallet that
they're going to use for every single
european citizen for much more than just
just your vac status so we gotta we're
gonna go super chats i just wanna give a
shout out to uh denmark man
you've probably been there a lot right i
actually that's the one country i
haven't been to i've never i've never
been to denmark it's been norway i've
been yeah i've been to norway i've been
to sweden i've never been to denmark but
i would love to go i'm just you know i'm
reading these countries i saw denmark
was on the list of like you can freely
travel there and i've it's it's weird
i've been to copenhagen so many times
and christiana have you ever have you
ever traveled there negative the free
city of christianity oh i've heard of
that yeah they like declared
independence from europe
and they're just kind of like no one
pays taxes or something it's crazy
amazing so you can communicate works it
says now leaving the eu i mean this
business isn't there when got a hot dog
yeah it was cool there's a great burger
place in copenhagen i loved going there
that was fun have you been to amsterdam
uh yes i have okay yeah
a lot of bikes a lot of bikes yeah yes
yes
i was only there for like a couple days
though did you take mushrooms no i went
do you think you will next time no i
don't think so
i went to a conference and talked about
the news and then everybody was riding
bikes everywhere it was funny yeah he's
like the bikes have like more rights
than cars yeah first time my first time
i rode a bike in amsterdam
yeah i crashed on the bike
what happened first time well i thought
it would be like an american mountain
bike and i get on this bike this
amsterdam dutch bike
and i thought i was going to really
impress ava oh no
and i ran into a range rover humbling
yeah very humbling which i needed so it
was good thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there